Attack on titan, in Japanese, the attack titan,
is literally about Eren, attacking all of
Humanity as a titan. In the end, Eren becomes
what he hates most. It's an anti-war story,
about a protagonist that turns out to have
been the villain, but also victim of the story
all along. And Eren is probably the most misunderstood
character I have ever seen.
So attack on titan is finally over, the reviews
are in, aaaand - everyone seems to have hated
it. I have come across are broad spectrum
of things people didn't like about how the
story wrapped up, but the most-commonly named
factor I heard, was without any doubt Eren,
the supposed main character of the story,
massacring his way through the last few arcs,
without giving us the big twist at the end
that everyone was apparently hoping for. No
satisfying ending, no coherent character development,
no big aha-moment to reveal that Eren was
the good guy all along, that we all wanted
him to be. And admittedly, I personally have
not been a fan of some of the writing throughout
the series, with the Manaka explicitly stating
his difficulties with writing and even understanding
his own main character.
And yet, I want to argue with this video,
that Eren's character was consistent from
start to finish and that his ending not only
makes sense, but is actually just as deep
as you were hoping for. But make sure to let
me know your perspective, once you've watched
it.
Before we get into it, if you want to re-live
the story of attack on titan or simply enjoy
the last volume as a whole, now is your chance.
I have partnered up with Bookwalker, an online
bookstore and app for reading Manga & Light
Novels digitally worldwide. Not only do they
have many of your favorite manga and light
novels, I've personally been reading Tokyo
Revengers and Vinland Saga recently, but they
also have countless other less-known fantastic
stories for you to explore as well. I really
like both their image and translation quality
as well as the overall reading experience.
And their coin system gives you the chance
to get big discounts on future purchases.
And right now, until the 27th of September,
they are running their Fantasy Fair 2021 campaign,
where you get 45% Coin Back on volumes 1 to
3 and 30% on any sequel volumes for many of
their stories, including attack on titan!
And on top, if you use my code, Ohara, you'll
even get 600yen, so a bit over 5 bucks off
as a new user. Link is in the description
below, so get reading, but not until you've
finished this video.
In many ways, I think that Eren, and more
generally attack on titan as a whole, fell
pray to its own success. It was the story
that popularized anime and manga outside of
Japan as probably no other story before, even
more than big shots like Dragon-ball, One
Piece and Naruto, pushing the genre into the
mainstream. And so, many people, me included,
put Attack on Titan side by side with many
other Shounen and other mainstream stories
as a more dark and bloody version of them.
And some kept that up until the very end,
until the very last chapter. However, when
the larger world and narrative behind the
story was reveled, with Marley and Eldia and
all the political, social and moral implications
around them, maybe later than necessary, I
understood that Attack on Titan does not only
not belong into the shounen genre, but in
many ways uses the anime and manga format,
to depict an incredibly dark and depressing
story. So it makes total sense to me that
its creator, Hajime Isayama, was taken aback
by its international success.
While we all knew that Eren Jaeger was no
conventional shounen Hero, Isayama never saw
him as any sort of hero for the story in the
first place. He is the protagonist, sure,
but as it turned out after the time skip,
we were watching the story of the complex
and morally grey villain of the story. The
backstory and ultimately the downfall of the
man who killed not only a character here or
there, or even a crowd of bystanders, but
80% of the worlds population. Can we please
appreciate for a second how bizarre that wiki
entry is?
So yes, my opinion is that Eren is both morally
grey and capable of good, but looking at the
end-result nonetheless the villain of the
story. He is however, a villain that tries
to be the hero, though he ultimately fails.
He is a beautiful example of the rare negative
character arc. Negative not because the arc
is bad, but in the sense that the character
develops, but instead of growing to become
a better person, he grows to become a worse
one. Let me explain:
Normally, a positive arc, we know from most
of our heroes, has the hero start from a negative
place. He has some ideal or believe that has
a negative impact on him and those around
him, so he needs to change. Throughout the
story, he might have moments of darkness and
failure, but generally moves in the right
direction until in the end, when the moment
of truth comes, he finally understands his
flaw and makes the right choice, becoming
a better person and giving us the happy end
we need. A negative arc, such as Eren's is
the inversion of this. The character starts
with a similar flaw, but from a much more
positive looking start point. Eren always
has his angry and violent side and difficulties
being vulnerable, but his hard work and determination
to protect his friends and fight for freedom,
seem to point him in the right direction.
However instead of moving into the right direction,
we see Eren slowly falling deeper and deeper
into his feelings of rage and helplessness,
punctured by moments of positivity, for instance
during his fight with Annie, after Armin sacrificed
himself for his sake or during the events
in the crystal cave. But despite these moments
of insight, Eren degreases further and further
away from his original goal, until finally
he is faced with the choice to murder 80%
of humanity or simply stop. And he chooses
the rumbling over his humanity. In many ways,
he has the most linear development out of
all characters in the last part of the story.
Because most character arcs in Attack on Titan
actually seem to be somewhat circular. Annie
still wants to run away back to her father,
because that’s what he told her to do when
he was a little girl. Mikasa starts with the
desire to be a normal family with Eren, and
after all she went through, she is still codependent
on him until the end. Armin still sees himself
as weak and unimportant, despite wielding
the strongest titan and being a commander.
It's a story about kids turned into soldiers,
that can't grow up and move on from their
childhood ideals and beliefs, due to all the
cruelty and violence around them, something
Falco and Gabi represent in the latest arc,
by mirroring Eren and
co. These characters don't follow a character
arc. As much as they follow a character circle,
breaking out of their bad habits and beliefs,
only to fall right back into them.
And even though you may or may not like it,
and believe me, I totally get it, I prefer
happy ends myself, but this has nothing to
do with bad writing. It's just unconventional.
So how did it all come to this?
One of my favorite things about Attack on
Titan's writing, was the shamelessly abrupt
change of narrative perspective from before
to after the time skip. For the first three
seasons, until we reach the sea, we basically
share the same misleading and propagandized
perspective of our protagonists. The premise
seems pretty clear: All that is left of humanity
lives inside the walls of the last standing
bastion, facing the inhuman and soul-less
titans, that with their grotesque looks and
moments, hunt humans. Attack on titan seemed
ah pretty clear set up to me for humanity
vs the monsters. Oh oh, okay, so now Eren
can transform into a titan, but it's okay
he only uses this power to fight the evil
monsters. Argh, but then we find out, that
he's actually not the only one that can do
this, actually it turns out all the titans
were actually not soul-less beasts to begin
with, but people turned beast against their
will. So it's actually Attack on Human's I
guess? And that actually fits pretty perfectly.
Uff and there is a lot of intrigue and political
games going on, and the ones in power chose
to leave thousands of their soldiers and civilians
to be slaughtered by the titans, before letting
anyone learn the truth. Slowly but steadily,
season by season, the horror of the titans
makes way to the horror of people and season
3 ends with World War II imagery, leaving
the titan powers a mere weapon of mass destruction.
With the time skip, just as Eren and co, we
suddenly break free from the worldview, which's
propaganda has been spoon-fed to us since
chapter 1. As it turns out, what we thought
to be the vast last resort of humanity, was
actually just a tiny island in a world rich
with people and cultures. And as it turns
out, Attack on titan is not a story about
humans fighting monsters, it's a story about
humans fighting humans or monsters fighting
monsters. A story about racism and war and
how they lead to a never-ending cycle of hatred
and oppression. The titans in the end only
exists as a tool of oppression and the cause
of racism in this world, which is ultimately
why their true origin and the secret behind
their creation doesn't matter in the end.
The main catalyst for Eren's inability to
grow is the lost of his mother. Having her
unconditional love taken away, traumatizes
him so extremely that it makes him incapable
of growing into a true adult. However, we
know that Eren already carried anger and violence
inside him, when he murdered the two traffickers,
who try to take Mikasa. Both we and Mikasa
took it as a pure act of kindness however,
however the version of Eren that gently wraps
the scarf around her head, the version that
Mikasa believes him to be until the very end,
and that undoubtedly exists inside Eren, never
makes it past his anger. And this is the key
to Eren's last words at the end, that left
so many people disappointed. The truth however
is, that Eren, never had a clear motivation
for his actions. Yes he wanted to protect
his friends and change the world, but above
all, Eren always hated the fact that
the world was cruel and he had no agency in
it. Eren wanted the choice to do something.
He was so traumatized by not being able to
do anything about his mother being killed,
that he took control over the world, to stop
the world controlling him. Instead of facing
and accepting his own humanity and vulnerability,
he selfishly tries to control everything around
him. If you read closely in the last chapter,
Eren changes his reasoning from “I was doing
it all to set up you as heroes of the world”
to“I would have done it anyway even if
you didn’t come to stop me” to“I don’t
know. I just wanted to.” Eren makes up stories
and reasons for his atrocities, looking for
a way to give them a greater meaning, when
there really is not. That's why it only makes
sense, that there was no great twist in his
plan at the end. Eren felt justified in his
actions at every step of the way. If eren
really wanted to do it for his friends, why
did he hurt them, as armin said. What is the
point? But it's all about having a choice
for Eren. And to get that choice, that ultimate
freedom he wants, he takes it away from everyone
around him. So the fact that Eren's reasoning
doesn'T make scenes, is actually not a flaw,
but a fundamental part of his personality.
Eren begins his life with“You were born
into this world, you’re free to live however
you want” and ends his life wishing he was
never born, and that’s the ultimate tragedy
of his character arc. Not that it was inevitable
he would eventually do these things, but because
it was not and Eren chose to do them anyway
instead of choosing literally anything else.
As we know there were plenty of options for
him to just stop and everyone begging him
to do so. Therefore, despite claiming Mikasa
and Armin as the reason behind all of his
actions, they weren’t, because he was incapable
of making the simple choice to be with them
and grow up with them which is all they ever
wanted from him. All Eren ever wanted was
agency and control, but what he really needed
was allowing himself to be vulnerable and
accept the unconditional love he had from
Armin and Mikasa, that his foil Zeke was denied
all his life.
What unites the tragic sties of Eren, Zeke,
Reiner and many others, is that they all act
based on a sense of entitlement because of
what has happened to them. They were oppressed
and the victim of a brutal life, and they
used that fact as justification for their
actions even past the point where they had
gained so much power, that they became the
oppressors. All of them committing genocide
and war crimes, still feeling like they are
the true victims here.
Eren gets the lesson, that he is not the only
one that suffers in this world shoved in his
face over and over again. But right until
the end, he fails to see the true feelings
of the people around him, because he won't
even allow himself to face his own fears,
hopes and dreams. He rejects Armin's dreams,
even though they used to be his own, just
as he rejects Mikasa's love, even though he
clearly loves her.
There is definitely room to criticize the
writing in Attack on Titan, a brutal anti-war
story about monster adults creating monster
children in a world where the motivations
and beliefs of every single character come
from their traumatizing childhoods. However,
I think you can't deny the beauty in Eren
literally becoming the Attack titan that threatens
to wipe out all of humanity, exactly what
the story seemed to be about at the start.
The essence of what he used to hate the most,
a giant monster, that toys with the lives
or all for no good reason whatsoever. Eren
becoming the enemy of humanity then is the
tragic story of a traumatized kid, robbed
of his chance for a happy and normal life
by the cruel world around him.
The unseeing, but bright happy end of Eren's
gruesome arc then, is that his dream of getting
rid of the titans, the symbol for oppression
and death, ends with his death. And Mikasa,
who was unable to break free from her codependent
love for him, is the tragic hero who takes
the life of the man she loves, still seeing
in him the beauty of the world, that Eren
never could.